you know people are talking or
chattering like those type of
everybody's sharing it together when
you're on your phone having a side
conversation
yeah like literally they're watching
instagram [__] videos yeah like yo
what the [__] are you doing man i pissed
me off i was like dude i was about to be
in a [__] jackfruit article
david so commits asian on asian crime
tells these asian people to go back to
asia
well what's your history with in five
four three two one
happy new year everybody what's up we
are back again with ed
park
genius brain listeners cheers apologies
for making genius brain once every it's
only once a week now yeah so people are
like oh where's the thursday one it's
like it might come back we'll see what's
up maybe but as of right now
this is very nice dude
so on new year's
i actually uh went to watch uh
spider-man right [__] let me tell you
something
i never missed arc light so much in my
life right because i haven't been to a
theater since like shang chi right right
with shang chi i had a terrible
experience anyway so it didn't matter
people who talked to that whole thing
you know i thought we might go without
mentioning that but all right
but there's a good thing
about that film right i just can't stop
it because people keep messaging me you
know i was gonna bring it up too [__] it
whatever so like the
like arc light if you guys haven't been
to an arc light before right arclight is
a cinema experience yeah you don't just
number one if people talk in arc light
they kick you out right um before they
have the film they talk about who the
directors are who the actors are
um and they kind of set like a tone for
for a movie watching experience yeah
when i was at arclight years ago i
remember uh people were talking super
loud and i was thinking you know
irritate everybody else was before
anybody got to say anything they kicked
them right out nice they're like you're
out nice like they warned them once they
wouldn't listen and they
stopped the film and they kicked them
out
yeah because they were so loud yeah but
they they they apologized to everybody
and they kind of restarted the film
experience again get a free ticket on
the way out yeah
you know i i really really love arclight
yeah no like they'll they have
especially the one on sunset boulevard
yeah
i went there to watch um let's see
winter soldier and the [__] directors
the russo brothers showed up oh thank
you yeah yeah so like that i guess
i've missed it a lot too especially for
the cinerama dome yes it's a part of
history and it just sucks that it's just
sitting there right now like doing
nothing dude freaking um
so i was at the theater and there was a
very specific part in spider-man and
there's like some very emotional cues in
the film right
there was three people behind me that
were talking throughout the whole
[__] film right never happens in
arclight which is why i only went to
arclight and i went to we went to
watching an imax yeah so it was like 26
a ticket it's not [__] cheap [__]
expensive you know it's [__]
expensive which theory did you go to
this time uh we went to the one in
alhambra right oh my god oh [__] dog
dude that's where i saw uh dune with my
brother-in-law and sister and
yeah it was like man and whatever no
dude so we were sitting there and you
know through in the beginning of the
film
people were talking behind us yeah right
and i kind of like just gave them like a
quick look a very nice like
keep it down a little bit
because they're talking they're
literally talking to them
and i'm just being chill about it or
whatever
i i kind of like communicated them too
like just
like two or three times and i wasn't
even irritated then like i understand
you like you're watching a film you're
getting hyped or whatever what not right
but it wasn't even like them talking
about the film it was them giggling and
laughing about something on their phone
[__] and so
naturally 20 a 26 dollar [__] ticket
in imax i'm getting a little irritated
right now and i just let it go cause i'm
like you know what it's a new year
[__] new david so whatever
we're watching and
spoiler alert if you guys haven't
watched it well it doesn't matter we're
doing a movie review anyways but the
scene where uh marissa tome aunt may
yeah is [__] dying yeah
they're [__] cackling behind me oh
god i
they that was a very pivotal moment in
the film yeah i got so [__] mario's
next to me i was like shut the [__] up
yeah
yeah they got really quiet
and i turned around and i just kept
staring at him i was like
what the [__] are you doing shut the
[__] up yeah and you know everybody too
there was like a few people in the
theater they could they were kind of
like thank god because they were all
irritated too but it was literally this
dude he was just [__] yapping his
[__] mouth off it's like him and his
friend and i think his girlfriend too
and i went outside
and i was like i wonder what the [__]
this guy looks like right because i'm
gonna beat this
it was like it was like two asian guys
and the only thing i could think of was
like if i beat him is this still
considered asian
[Laughter]
what's the article gonna say you know my
gosh i mean even for all the listeners
out there like why why why do you do
that man like why are you here that's
that makes people not want to go too and
it just ruins the experience for
everybody dude just go home yeah and you
know like i understand like if we're
watching like some [__]
like if i'm watching like a stupid
comedy people are laughing and making
jokes or whatever i think that's a part
of the experience but we're here in an
imax
it's 26 a ticket yeah
i think you might like uh what's it
downtown uh
alamo drafthouse have you been there
it's pretty dope like um
it's got a super retro vibe to it and
when you go in it's all reclining seats
and you order food they've got a menu on
each table oh really yeah and you get a
white piece of paper and you you write
what you want and you live it leave it
hang it up and they'll come and i'll
bring you everything and then you have a
credit card on tab oh [__] so you pay
for it i'm gonna try this [__] out man
they got rules too like no phones no
talking will kick you out like they're
it's a really great experience yeah it's
like i don't understand like when you're
going to a [__] theater it's like why
why do you do this like what are you
here just wait for the [__] dvd guy
but i think at the draft house it's kind
of like people are like
really aware of that rule yeah so when
like andrew garfield and toby mcguire uh
spoiler by the way we're [__] talking
spoilers right when they came out like i
could hear people go
like they're holding it in
like
and i understand like yeah any other uh
like theater like hype marvel like fan
theater they they were probably cheering
like crazy but if you don't like that
then alan will draft it quiet as [__]
yeah like when we when we watch it like
when i say you know people are talking
or chattering like those type of
everybody's sharing it together when
you're on your phone having a side
conversation
yeah like literally they're watching
instagram [__] videos yeah like yo
what the [__] are you doing man i pissed
me off i was like dude i was about to be
in a [__] jackfruit article
david so commits asian on asian crime
tell these asian people to go back to
asia
but what's your history with spider-man
like so going back like i i think for me
it was this spider-man cartoon on fox
kids yep right because it was it came
out because of the success of the x-men
cartoons yes and so i i watched that
spider-man cartoon just as religiously
too but yeah i mean that was during our
age of like those 90s um superhero
cartoons like because they're gonna i'm
not even reboot but continue the x-men
series x-men 97 on disney plus i'm so
[__] hype i can already hear the
theme song right now
dude which is kind of crazy because i
thought they were just going to reboot
it yeah but it's just a continuation
from where it [__] left off that's
[__] awesome yeah it's dope [__] so
but we started like i mean
i mean just to preface this depending on
who's like listening to this
when i first started watching marvel
films it didn't matter what the marvel
film was i liked it because when i was a
little kid i was i mean these didn't
debut when i was a kid yeah but i had
lou ferrigno as the hulk
so like any any [__] marvel film was
dope to me just because of the graphics
right yeah it doesn't matter it didn't
matter which which spider-man it was it
was just kind of nice to see but after a
while you start to realize this is the
standard what marvel films are you get
to see what what the films are for what
they're worth yeah and spiderman has a
terrible go yeah a lot of other [__]
movies
so you know just um
one of the things that i i didn't
i was a little apprehensive of because
even the previous spider-man before this
one which is what no way home no
yeah no no far from far from home right
yeah i thought it was okay yeah
it was all right well that's the problem
that a lot of people have with this
peter parker um is that he's
i mean as a kid as a high school teenage
kid like
damn he's cool he's cool he's charming
and all that he's he's the right peter
parker
in for this generation right like gen z
peter parker
um but he's a [__] rich kid he's got
a rich his
uncle ben was tony stark he's like hey
like he's got dope suits he got you know
if he has a place to stay if he needs to
he has a ton of resources and all that
jazz but
um
i feel like the best representation of
peter parker was probably the tobey
maguire one because he's broke
right and and he's got a bunch of social
problems and all these things um
that that really worked for gen x yeah
yeah and then um
what's his name andrew garfield
he is the millennial spider-man
he's way too cool to meet peter parker
he's skateboards and he's like he's
really great at i mean
like just getting really beautiful women
seems easy for him yeah yeah yeah like
yeah so it was a little off on in that
sense see like all these spider-man's
had this this weird thing that i either
kind of like it was i kind of liked it
and then there was a lot of things more
i disliked about it right and the
biggest thing that i disliked about
the uh what's the new spider-man's name
tom holland tom holland tom holland
spider-man right was just in every
superhero arc right they have to go
through some type of trials and
tribulation to define who they are now
yeah what the [__] did this kid go
through i mean what he i so he lost tony
so did everybody else yeah right he did
but
that's one of the things that this film
kind of rectified for me right yes yes
it allowed him to have lost to allow him
to grow right
that was the weird part about the first
iteration of this spider-man was that
everyone was so tired of watching uncle
ben die
but it's one of the most important parts
of who what makes him him right because
at the same time people also complain
about seeing bruce wayne's parents die
in every single iteration of his movies
that's like what makes him better yeah
exactly it's like it's that's what makes
him him how is that a complaint what the
[__] are you talking about but i thought
it was really smart and then rectified
it
um by making it on may being his uncle
ben motivation and us seeing it through
into his third movie though and watching
why it's so devastating to him because
in the previous ones because it happens
in the first act of each of those origin
movies we don't really give a [__] about
who uncle ben is yeah yeah yeah he's
just kind of like that annoying dad it's
like dude shut the [__] up man yeah but
then if it's marissa tomei if i i
remember first from my cousin vinnie she
was a [__] cutie marissa tomei is one
of those actresses that i really
appreciate because
she's
to me anyways
she's so [__]
beautiful yeah
and you know this is not a knock on
other people like i said you know do
whatever the [__] you want to your face
but you know there's something that this
industry and city does to women that
makes them feel like they have to
constantly keep up with the joneses
especially when it comes to botox and
yeah aging
and you see marissa tomei she's aging
like a normal person still one of the
most beautiful women i've ever seen in
my life and it's it's kind of just nice
to see
yeah so we cared about her through the
first two movies yeah right um
especially like by the second one when
she knew he was spider-man and then like
told him encouraged him on his peter
tingle and then in this one where she
was the one that taught him that grape
with great power comes great
responsibility yeah and she didn't even
nicknack it and like change it she said
it exactly the way uncle ben did yeah
that that line it didn't like try to
change the vocabulary or nothing
and i thought that was amazing too
because
that was so devastating for him that he
ran away to his safe space or whatever
right and when the other spider-man
caught up to him
spider-man's
spiders man
[Laughter]
i thought it was really
i thought it was really important when
he goes you don't know what it's like
you don't know what i've just been
through and it was like no
that was my uncle ben and he says be
here same too and then when they talk
about their mjs or you know his his gwen
or whatever yeah like how important it
is to
reiterate no we're the same yeah we're
the same people like as much that was a
thing that i i really needed because
even with like i said it might be a
generational thing but it's just kind of
what i like about superheroes like
there's
because what's the whole point of having
a superhero without a weakness right it
doesn't really humanize them so with tom
holland's character it was just for me
it just felt like oh you're that [__]
kid that just has everything
so there was no reason for me to kind of
like
really be attached and you know what
they did it i think they did a really
good job in this film too because he was
doing a lot of [__] entertaining
things yeah that i think the audience
for me as an audience member i was
getting irritated like why i was even
sitting there like why would you do that
dude aren't you a [__] smart ass kid
but the biggest thing was is because
he's still a kid and i think like the
general theme was that they were trying
to tell us that he wants to have his
cake and eat it too yeah and it just
doesn't [__] work like that but it
also when his other spider-man came that
it was about that their responsibility
being that no they can cure these people
they don't have to die because doctor
strange was like trying to send them
back because in the instant they went
back they'd be dead yeah you know and
for peter's sake
i don't know pete's sake but yeah he was
he was trying to just
he was trying to save them he wanted he
didn't want to kill them he didn't want
them to die yeah it was a weird turn
where it kind of showed doctor strange
in an antagonistic like like
it was it was like the sinister five
right and it's like dr strange might
have been a sinister six yeah yeah
it came together really well honestly um
i thought in a sense like i will bring
up this theme later too because when it
got a little meta
was
they used it for comedy and i think it
worked because when you open up the
multiverse
before we continue this podcast my brain
farts we are brought to you by papa
purple listen
i don't know how many times i can tell
you this but i love my purple mattress i
wouldn't be talking about it every time
we do this podcast not only because they
are sponsors because i love my mattress
we spend a majority of our life sleeping
so i don't understand why you haven't
invested into a purple mattress legit
i've had sleeping problems my whole life
and that was because a big part of it
was just because i didn't sleep on
something that really supported my back
and the way that i slept and my purple
mattress has been a freaking godsend you
will not regret getting this and if
you're thinking well guess what um it's
a little bit too expensive well that's
why you're gonna use the promo code i'm
gonna give you at the end of this
podcast to save you guys a chunk of
money invest in yourself you will not
regret buying yourself a purple mattress
because the technology in their products
by the way it keeps me cool it supports
my back sides hips and necks and
shoulders everything that i need and
guess what you can't regret it because
there's free shipping and returns so
what are you waiting for getting a great
night's sleep starts with having a great
mattress get a purple mattress go to
purple.com brainted and use promo code
brain10 that's purple.com brain10 promo
code brain10 for 10 off any order of 200
or more purple.com brain 10 promo code
brain 10 terms apply it kind of explains
okay why are they so corny right or why
are they so
hammy like william the foe like god
bless him he was so good yes right he
[__]
powerbomb spiderman through the [__]
floor and [__] william defoe like i
forget
he could have done the joker how much i
love him yeah there was a scene in this
film that almost brought me back to i
mean obviously two different [__]
comic book universes but
dark knight
the it was literally that moment dude
this part actually gave me chills in the
film is when um tom holland spider-man
his [__] spider senses were going off
and he couldn't figure out why yeah he's
like what the [__] is going on why is my
why is everything in my body telling me
that something is wrong and then you see
it it's [__] hobgoblin yeah like he's
still hobgoblin or green goblin oh green
goblin i'm sorry yeah he's still green
goblin and i'm like oh [__] and you see
everything start to crumble slowly and
that scene where he's they're fighting
in the hallway
was so [__] intense yeah it was
amazing it was like
spider-man finally not pulling back his
punches he was hit they were going at it
yeah it was uh it was probably one of
the best fight scenes uh i mean
there's so many fight scenes in mcu but
this one was so one of the most visceral
ones it's just the payoff was right yeah
you know like you kind of see
his spider-man
lose that that that innocence that he
has right because like i said he wanted
to have his cake and eat it too he
thought everything was going just the
way that it should have look i'm saving
these people i saved doc ock i'm saving
all these other people
and then there's that one little thing
he didn't think about it's like wait
these are all villains
you know and when you see it kind of
crumble before him and you and you you
when in that fight you see him just
clipping him hard full on just letting
all his strength out and he still can't
do anything yeah it was almost just it
was sad yeah just watching this whole
[__] go down and yeah i i really
what i was kind of alluding to before
was appreciating
their performances like each villain's
performance was still according to the
universe that they came from yeah and
then the way they would explain it too
so they're like so you fell into a vat
of yeah
it's like you fell into this yeah and so
you fell into some sand yeah okay
the the here's what i liked about this
film the jokes were really [__] good
yeah they hit there was there was this
one line that cracked me the [__] up i
don't know why but it was just a simple
thing of
um ned he's asking um [__] uh tobey
maguire like so like who's your best
friend
he's like well i killed my best friend
and i killed his dad yeah and then he
came back as a villain to you know come
kill me
[__] andrew garfield's like dude
there was so much good jokes like also
too
i mean just to wrap it back to like
shang chi i think
it actually gave me hope that the second
shang chi is going to be better because
spider-man has had so many chances to
finally hit its stride yeah so i feel
like from this experience that sheng chi
the second one's going to be a lot
better having said that the jokes and
shane she were trash like so the the
metaness of this one was being aware
because the universe opened yeah where
each person is like why are you like so
you
you shoot webs from your wrist right
here was [__] a little bit but that
was one of the biggest complaints yeah
why the [__] is he coming from his
wrists
but then that was the point is like yeah
well i do yeah and that's just it and
he's just like it's perfectly normal for
him and yeah oh okay to accept it in
chiang chi the problem was
wow you just wrote a magical dragon
isn't that crazy
like why are you why are you mocking
what you just did yeah you know like it
then takes away from our story yeah
where in spider-man was like no this is
the way it is accepting the the meta
nature
of the situation they're in instead of
like wow your dad's a [__] maniac and
he's insane well
yeah and what do you do let's go because
also too like in the film like nobody
ever acknowledges uh shang's like
shitty behavior yeah you know it's like
it's just completely acceptable that
he's an [__] but it's just going
through the motivation it's that's why
it felt
it felt like you're just supposed to
accept it as it is and it's like that's
that shouldn't have to be the case yeah
and so that's what i'm saying like for
the second one i feel i i feel a lot of
hope just because spider-man got that
many chances i'm pretty sure like the
second like shanghai is going to be a
lot better and if not then it would it
would suck just because
and once again this is not knocking
anybody like on the film but you
know spider-man has such seasoned actors
so you could see it in their improv you
could see it in like how they were
delivering the jokes it was just better
yeah you know and i think that one of
the things that uh one of my friends
brought up to me he goes because he
watched ashanti on disney plus
and this one did not like our podcast
dude it was perfectly fine and he
watched it on disney plus and he goes
you [__] ruined the film yeah
and i was like i didn't ruin anything
for you dude i saw it for what it was
yeah and he goes i think he says
something that was very poignant he goes
i think why a lot of people enjoyed
chanchi beyond just the fact that it's
just the asian face was that we hadn't
seen a movie in theaters yeah
it's so long and so that was our first
experience for a lot of us specifically
a marvel fan and if you're in the right
room you know with the right hype of uh
people you know there to see it on
opening day i'm sure it was such a great
experience that you're gonna
feel differently about the film very
sentimentally that wow that was like
because one of my best theater
experiences was fast and furious five
dude fast five
and a lot of people hate it but you know
what i to this day i still love fast
five and i'll always remember that
opening night that i saw it everybody
loves fast five because they know it's
gonna be straight stupidity yeah like
any other type stupidity
but because there's like just a on just
because we're derailing a little bit but
i remember that one i forgot which was
it fast five where they had the tank and
dom toretto flew off the tank into a car
window that's that's
fast six okay
when i saw that part everybody started
cheering and they were crying laughing
because this will flew in and nothing
not a single scratch the windshield
stopped him
he had like a crispy shirt yeah like a
super crisp white shirt like it looked
like it was out of the bag and the lines
were still on there and i think that's
the thing everybody remembered were like
that's a brand new t-shirt
it's so clean and she was so [__]
funny man and that that is part of the
movie being self-aware about these super
human like physics breaking feeds yeah i
was like yeah this is fast and furious
yeah but then you can't treat other uh
other ip like that yeah this is the way
it is so i just accept it it's like no
it doesn't have to like that yeah that
it's hard when the studio like forces
down [__] down your throat like this is
the way it is and it's like no good
though one of the things i really i
think i couldn't really get over when i
watched spider-man the second time was
when um
just the whole beginning sequence of
doctor strange trying to
create the world where he doesn't
[__] up his friend's life right yeah as
he's creating these different realities
he goes oh can you add this oh can you
he goes yeah and he goes look what you
made me do but i'm like what the [__]
are you talking about dude yeah it was
it was it was a little stupid it was a
little too accessible it could be part
of um that's i think that's part of the
play did you see the post credits
yes the doctor strange uh
uh
what's it called multiverse
madness yeah i think that's where he's
gonna pay for his consequences yeah by
then um which i guess would set it up
real nice that he was just being so
would you
flimsy with this magic shield yeah just
like what the whole universe yeah he
goes okay i owe him a favor
but
in turn the spell he casts at the end
where it's make everyone forget who i am
make everyone forget who peter parker is
um
what that does inevitably
is take him to a place where that toby
mcguire spider-man was right where he's
a loser he's broke his [__] he's gonna
struggle hard and but he's still gonna
be a great hero yeah it's that great
power comes great responsibility and i
think that's the part where it made me
really like him it was that missing
piece that i always had in all of his
films it's
what makes you great yeah and he didn't
really have that peace and so when he
decided to sacrifice his whole life for
the better better of like the betterment
of the world is we're like this is what
makes him a [__] superhero and i
really appreciated that because i never
really had that with him i'm like you
you just get everything don't you
you know i'm like it was kind of cool
but that's the same reason why like if
we go to dc i love batman so much he's
like this troubled soul and he's always
trying to figure out how to do things
right despite his background yeah like
there's always a reason for the
superhero to do something even with like
superman right his whole [__] world
blew up his family is gone and you know
he's trying to somehow live this human
life but at the same time he's
technically a god in this world yeah and
with this spider-man he gave up
everything and now he has to start back
from square one
which is
honestly what makes him great yeah he
decided to sacrifice for the better and
i i really really [__] like that part
too especially like
i think like the the scene that really
got me to that that i [__] enjoyed
was when um was at last scene two when
he was fighting green goblin right and
he was going [__] ham dude yeah so it
wasn't like this very easy accessible
thing of like
these guys told me i'm better i'm not
going to try to kill him no he was going
to kill he was going to kill him yeah
and that's what's so great about the the
tobey mcguire peter parker coming in
where he becomes the mentor spider-man
just like into the spider-verse
and i [__] love that yeah i love that
he was like like just a cool dad kind of
spiderman he's like you're an avenger
that's awesome
what is that
but i was cracking the [__] up dude
the jokes were placed so [__] well
and yeah it works so well and and it's
so great for those other two spider-man
because their third i mean their next
sequels like spider-man 4 with toby
maguire and spider-man 3 with andrew
garfield was canceled yeah both of them
were canned and there were things that
that were supposed to happen apparently
and it ended so unceremoniously for them
yeah that this spider-man
is their closing for them yeah and i
thought that was great too so it's like
if you want to see what happens next
like
just
after spider-man 3 with venom just pull
this one yeah i really like the fact
that you know because i mean i forgot
that doc ock's problem was the chip
right and with this tony stark's
technology it allowed him to fix the one
thing that made him go crazy yeah that
[__] felt so
good yeah yeah cause doc ock the the
auto octavius yeah
it was a friend of peter parker's right
he was a mentor to peter he was a very
strict father type figure to him that's
why when they meet again at the end it
was so heartwarming yeah like you grew
up kind of thing yeah and
yeah the the callbacks in it were great
too um
well he didn't [__] age the actor oh
um auto octave
i'm pretty they did the uh de-aging on
him for sure oh okay him and william
defoe yeah oh because they're supposed
to come straight out of the year they
came out i was like how come he looks
like exactly the same
[__] they did it to samuel jackson you
know throughout uh captain marvel oh
that's right
yeah yeah that's the whole time
dude the [__] technology is amazing
yeah yeah dude i think all these like 70
80 year old actors look uh the irishmen
they were all [__] dh too right yeah
yeah that the aging tech has come such a
long way that those old ass actors can
make a huge comeback
just like watching how
william defoe is just so [__] good
man
yeah i think so many people forgot since
he was away for so long it was a really
good redemption movie for a lot of
people who are just as shitty spiderman
[__] jamie foxx too super funny
throughout the whole film he came back
like that was my
biggest [__] issue with
his character coming as an he so he's a
[__] nerd who's a spider-man fanatic
right
and then a major accident
um
causes him to
i don't know suddenly turn crazy right
that's a that's a huge trope in comic
book movies where for some reason
whoever somebody who's kind of close
semi-close to our protagonist
has this antagonistic turn but not only
do they hate them they also go insane
for some reason they go like crazy yeah
so jamie foxx in this one he's like a
hyper
hyper extra like stereotype typical nerd
yeah right and then he falls into a
vatta electric field as [__] yeah
his [__] space between his teeth come
together too
and then he comes like and it becomes
like super cool or whatever but then i
think they were just like kind of
retconned that [__] they were just like
all right you're you're fine you're just
a normal dude
when uh when aunt may got hit in the
back of the head with the with the gree
green goblin saucer thing yeah eyeing a
lot i kind of laughed a little bit
that [__]
i kind of kept it in bit but
it was just like so excited i was like
the [__] was that
and then like the back of her head was
being i was like oh she's going to die
man yeah i think they were meant to make
it look pretty violent yeah she got hit
super hard on the back of the head i was
like oh [__] and when she was kind of
fine with it i'm like it's whack oh no
my she's dying yeah she doesn't know
where she's at so yeah she's like
completely [__] losing it yeah this
podcast is sponsored by better help
online therapy we talk about better help
a lot on the show and this month we are
discussing some of the stigmas around
mental health for instance some people
think you should wait until things are
unbearable to go to therapy but that
just isn't true therapy is a tool to
utilize before things get worse and it
can help you avoid those lows many
people think therapy is for so-called
crazy people but therapy doesn't mean
something's wrong with you guys
it means you recognize that you know all
humans have emotions and you know we
need to control them and not avoid them
listen i've used it and i've talked
about it multiple times on this podcast
once again a lot of these sponsors they
wouldn't be sponsoring me consistently
if it's something that i didn't enjoy
it's super easy it's convenient and you
might like it too so you have nothing to
lose better help is a customized online
therapy that offers video phone and even
live chat sessions with your therapist
so you don't have to see anyone on
camera if you don't want to it's much
more affordable than in-person therapy
and you can be matched with the
therapist in under 48 hours just give it
a try and see why over 2 million people
have used better health online therapy
and this podcast is sponsored by
betterhelping geniusbrainlisters get 10
off their first month at betterhelp.com
genius that's betterhelp.com
genius
no it was a great movie um threw him
through i i didn't get a chance to see
it again because my
roommate caught cove and i've been in
quarantine for the past couple weeks so
yeah i would definitely finally go out
to see it now
yeah this is like
yeah it was just that one thing it was
just how easily accessible the whole
doctor strange thing is because but at
the same time
they did a good job in some of the lines
where he was he said it very poignantly
he goes i keep forgetting that you're
just a kid and
how he tries to solve all these problems
it's like how a kid would solve it oh we
could just get these guys together
what's the big deal i don't know they're
[__] villains that kill people yeah
you know yeah he doesn't um have a whole
lot of foresight he doesn't see what's
like three steps ahead of him he only
sees one possibility
and just very much like a lot of
immature
kids do
and that's the point that people missed
with peter quill star-lord in infinity
war
when um they had thanos all wrapped up
right and like
the [__] antenna girl
had put him in a trance yeah and then
peter quill went up to him he's like
where's gamora and freaks out that he
killed her so
he [__] hits him in the face yeah and
people are like why the [__] would you
do that it's like don't forget
his whole character in the guardian
series is that he's an immature 11 year
old he got [__] abducted when he was
11. and so he never grew up he's a peter
pan basically um yeah so he he has major
maturity issues
in the first two guardians movies yeah
yeah yeah it carries on through um his
you can see it with his bickering with
thor too oh yeah yeah yeah yeah the way
he bickers with everybody that's like
that's like two i think like one of the
parts that kind of bothered me but i i
kind of forgave it when i watched the
second time was when aunt may kind of
came up to him and she was like are you
doing this for you are you doing it for
them and then he was like
you're right
he kind of goes about his way but then i
also had to realize that that's like his
mom
and he's still a little kid and he still
loves and he has a great relationship
with aunt may yeah and he respects
everything that she says so it's it's
his moral beacon and so yeah i think as
an adult if it was like adult spider-man
it might be a little weird but
from a kid's perspective that's very
impulsive it makes sense yeah because
even in the the first toby mugar
spider-man they're already in college
yeah by the end of the first movie right
um
the
i don't know but is he still in high
school in the andrew garfield spider-man
yes because he was in the gym i remember
the scene oh where he play [__] plays
basketball yeah
[__] cool guy here dude yeah cool
spider-man man
that's what i that's the other problem i
had with other spider-man is that they
do these amazing [__] feats only a
spider could do but everyone's high
school is like wow peter parker's cool
not a single basketball scout came out
they're like yo maybe we should get them
on our team
that's why in the gym scenes in tom
holland spider-man shows him holding
back
where when he's doing all these crunches
like crazy and then his coach tells me
he's doing a good job oh he starts to
like try to act like he's struggling to
do it yeah cause it's too easy for him i
i also like that when um you know when
he wasn't using his like peter tinkle as
she calls it or spider tingle or
whatever i remember when she gave him
that heads up and threw that [__] at him
hit him in the face
she was she's your [__] peter tingled
yeah
yeah that's that's the great part that's
why i love that they casted tom holland
because he's still a a kid yeah and they
should treat him as like as he was a
high school kid they're they're not
smart people that's why you don't cast
30 year olds play teenagers
you know like they high schoolers if
you've been around to do some dumb [__]
exactly yeah i think it was kind of cool
too where
i actually appreciated the uh the ned
character because in the previous film
um films that he was acting in yeah i i
did not like his acting
yeah it wasn't very this film though he
was a lot more comfortable
i i think
i hope at least that he's taking uh
acting classes in between yeah because
in some iterations of the spider-man
comic book ned becomes a hop goblin
spoiler alert but
wait that's right that's why that
internal thing when he was asking about
his best friend yeah that's why he's
like oh you know i would never you know
become an enemy to you or some of that
yeah yeah yeah just cause in the comics
he does yeah he be he becomes what the
hobgoblin writer yeah like in some other
spider-man universe storyline yeah do
you know how he becomes a hobgoblin no i
just know that he does yeah
because that was the interesting too
like what i remember because before i
watched um
no way home i watched the previous ones
and it
he he kind of stuck out like a sore
thumb a little bit he was he was very
very stiff yeah and i'm like i hope he's
gonna get better in the third one it
wasn't terrible but it's like the third
one he was a lot better so something was
he was doing something in between where
i think he just kind of
whether he actualized his character a
little bit better but the jokes were
hitting harder his like his his lines
weren't as stiff it was just really good
to watch he lost a lot of weight for
this one too right yeah cause he was
huge in the first half second one you
could see his skin lines like even on
his cheeks yeah he lost that weight he
so he doesn't have hair
yeah he's normally bald too in real life
yeah you know what the funny thing is is
like i've never really watched the
interviews oh i just kind of watched the
film i didn't really like the film so i
never really went back and watched
anything about it
and then i was looking at it and i'm
like wait i thought his hair looks like
a wig
i was watching all the tom hall i was
like wait he's bald yeah he's straight
bald is he like alopecia or is it like
no i think he's like
close to 30 years old right now too oh
is he yeah i think when he did the first
spider-man he was like 26.
oh for real yes he looks young yeah i
mean that's that asian down raisin like
yes
it was kind of cool too i think for a
lot of filipino people when they saw the
the filipino mom come in and they were
she was speaking like the goblet yeah
and she was tied to just a really funny
funny scene where she's asking to get
the spider webs
at the corner yeah they just take the
time to all right
if it went up and he grabbed the [__]
roof and she still wasn't sure if he's
like the real spider-man
yeah dude uh yeah it came together
really tightly it was great [__]
story it was acted really well it it's
opening up to a great new trilogy coming
out with you know tom holland like
it's going to be great bro venom was
terrible
and we talked about how [__] bad that
movie was the first and second one first
answer yeah i thought the second one was
going to be good no it was worse it was
bad it was like a ten-year-old wrote it
like who wrote that one
the same two guys who wrote the first
one and well why did they give him
another chance this [__] was so bad
because the first one made like a
billion dollars or some [__] it did
really well in the box office but it was
so well it was the first vet
yeah people want to see venom yeah um
it's just
yeah i did not like them at all like i
i've completely just written them out in
my head like that they don't exist it
was so bad like i i don't understand
first of all like
venom's story is so good it's already
there yeah i mean he's supposed to be in
new york
in brooklyn he's from brooklyn right
yeah he's supposed to be peter parker's
like antagonist at the daily bugle but
uh
i guess they that's that's the thing
where where i'm seeing it like
they know venom's hot venom is a super
popular character they own the rights to
him sony's like just make a movie even
though it's not gonna fit the storyline
of what our current spider-man's doing
just release it just make a movie and
that's what the first one was and it was
you know it was decent i never watched
it more than once yeah you know but the
the second one
the second one was like
a 10 year old tried to write uncut gems
with venom in it
it was such incoherent dialogue
incoherent just all this craziness did
you finish it i couldn't finish it no i
i saw it at the theater with two of my
friends and i paid for their tickets i
said let's go watch venom right because
a friend was visiting from virginia
it was so bad that all three of us
looked at each other like yeah let's
leave right damn you so you're watching
in theater theater and i walked i never
walked out of a theater these are
expensive i saw at the pacific theaters
at the the [__]
americana yeah
dude i yeah like i said
i've never walked out of a theater
because it costs so much for a ticket
now but i went to the the kiosk and i
was like can i get a refund they were
like it's already 45 minutes in we don't
give refunds
for me
i was like it's better to walk away and
lose this money then go back in there
and sit down and watch this
and all three of us agreed we were like
yeah i would rather not go in 45 minutes
though i went in like maybe 25 and oh my
gosh i'm like
i can't watch this one incoherent mess
right that first act was like like as if
you're turning pages of a comic book
crazy fast like what the hell like in my
mind i'm thinking like were you on speed
when you cut this film yeah there was an
entire movie in there in that first
opening scene trying to explain
what the hell was going on it's so
stupid yeah the pacing and the jump
jumping around in the jungles you know
what happened in the end of the film i
never even went back to care to watch it
no i i didn't pull it up again
[__] point yeah i i it didn't matter
to me at all it was just so bad that it
didn't matter there was just you know
when we talk about
spider-man like i remember just watching
the
cartoon and how impactful it is it's
crazy how
like i watch my friends kids and
they're super into marvel too just like
we are yeah obviously their stuff is a
lot more high tech and stuff but like
their love and fervor for marvel films
is just the same as when we were younger
yeah which is kind of crazy like even
something like like pokemon you know
kids still love pokemon yeah i i totally
missed that train like i'm in that age
group where i never even actually played
it
or the game or anything no
for reals yeah so i have no like
sentimentality towards it i like i my
brother and sister played it you know
but i i don't have the sentimentality
but like when people when that pokemon
go craze came out
i was just watching everybody outside my
window like oh like rushing together
and i'm just watching like i mean i
guess it looks fun
like i i never really got into it i
tried doing did let me tell you how lazy
i am
uh i tried getting into a pokemon go but
i realized that i had to like actively
walk around and search for things
so
my brother got me this like watch that's
attached to your phone yeah that kind of
just catches pokemon automatically as
you just walk around and do normal [__]
so you don't have to look at your phone
literally the laziest piece of [__] ever
and then i hacked my iphone at the time
to just instead of me walking i could
make my character walk without having to
control your
gps stay where you are
that would be like
i'd be like in like south africa you go
to the himalayas
i'm catching all these obscure pokemon
because i was that [__] lazy wow dude
people lost weight playing pokemon oh
yeah oh yeah it was a huge craze like
that like it made all these people just
get up and walk people still play it
till this day really not not as crazy as
before but right
i remember just uh going to
my local like coffee places and you see
people at like these monuments these
like fountains or whatever collecting
pokeballs and [__] wow and they're doing
it raids like in a group of friends
also i guess it's still going on i mean
people still do play counter-strike
right
it's as if people could go out and get
out together yeah i think it was good
too because it even though people were
on their phones it was nice to see
people just go outside and do outdoor
activities which is something that a lot
of people don't really do nowadays
that's a great thing for a [__] video
game to do
dude there was a i read an article where
there was a guy who lost like 60 pounds
nice because he was so obsessed with
pokemon go he would just constantly walk
around his [__] neighborhood and just
catch pokemon
so
now he's just a fit guy he's still
catching pokemon though yeah
after the uh the game dot he's fat again
nah but um the other movie we saw right
uh that came out like couple days after
was a matrix resurrections aka matrix
part four dude so i only got to watch
you watched it multiple times yeah
um
just to kind of preface this
uh i think we might have talked about
this on the podcast too but there is
this whole
i don't know what happened with the
lawsuit exactly right but there's this
whole talk and conspiracy about matrix
the original script being stolen from
this lady yes
back in the
like
i think the 80s i guess
she sued warner brothers specifically
because i guess they
well not warner brothers she sued
a couple uh studios because
the script also came out of uh
terminator 2. this podcast is brought to
you by uncommon
goods this valentine's day the way to
their heart is through uncommon goods my
friends one-of-a-kind gifts that are
perfect for your one-of-a-kind
love uncommon goods has hundreds of
gifts that you can customize based on
your unique love story and not only that
they also offer a wide variety of
uncommon experiences that make the
perfect romantic date night these live
virtual classes include topics like
aphrodisiac cooking for two rare magic
and mixology ooh romantic map making and
a whole bunch more and let's just talk
about their high quality unique and
often handmade or made in the u.s
products they had the most meaningful
out of the ordinary gifts anywhere i
actually bought a whole bunch of stuff
recently during christmas time at
uncommon goods and everybody loved their
gifts that's no cap i'm being serious i
actually love
uncommon goods if you've ever gotten a
[__] gift from somebody just because
they didn't really take the time to kind
of look into really dope gifts i
guarantee you you get them something
from uncommon goods they're going to
love it legit didn't have a bad
experience from giving out these gifts
this year and i love it and you know
valentine's day is coming up my friends
you better get that in in so to get 50
off your next gift go to
uncommongoods.combrain that's
uncommongoods.combrain for 15 off don't
miss out on this limited time offer
uncommon goods we're all out of the
ordinary
so because of the whole machine war oh
yeah yeah yeah so she was saying that
these two franchises stole my initial
idea from her short stories oh she even
went after terminator terminator yeah
james cameron
for reals did she win that one that's
what i i i think from
the latest i heard either i think she
won a settlement so it was just like
don't talk about it ever again and since
then they've been just pumping out all
these sequels if you've noticed why is
there so many terminator sequels now
and such terrible ones man they're
terrible ones right it's just you got to
keep releasing it and just keep pumping
it and make money out of it i guess
but that's that's the conspiracy-ish
so when you but when you watch this one
you're like did the same person write
the first movie yeah well see this is
the thing right because i remember
watching i mean how old were we when
matrix came out 1999 i was 14.
okay so i was
thirteen so i was like you know what
junior higher right yeah right i was
like a freshman my older hyungs you know
bought me the tickets cause they were
18. yeah
yeah that was one of the greatest
experiences of my life too oh that's
right i actually watched i think i
watched the matrix in korea
and i and then they had like korean
subtitles for it but i could just listen
to it straight up yeah um but
matrix was very the first one was so
[__] good and i actually went back
and watched the first one it's still
holding and it's still so [__] good
yeah it's still visually unique
as many parodies as there could be out
there um no movie still matches the way
it looks the way it feels the [__]
intensity of it the pacing of it the
all of the inspirations that they took
from anime and and hong kong and wusha
films like it's all in there it's just
such a great unique piece of cinema i
think when uh later on when i watched it
you know i've probably seen the first
matrix at least like 10 or 12 times now
and um
when i started reading up more about
film and like how it was shot and kind
of like
the way that each frame was kind of made
i was like no wonder i like this [__]
it's [__] anime yeah it's not amazing
i like no wonder i like this [__] have
you seen the matrix storyboards yeah it
looks like a manga yeah it's great it's
the storyboards are some of the best
storyboards you'll see yeah it looks
like a really awesome comic book and
they filmed it that way it looks like
epic and amazing and wide beautiful yeah
i'll tell you this it's not very easy to
do cowboy bebop
[Laughter]
fashion
so fast oh man that's so sad man i heard
some people met okay listen
friends out there i know you guys were
doing brand deals and
saw a lot of friends do brand deals with
cowboy bebop they're like listen
a lot of people don't know but it's
actually a lot better than you think you
are going to help
you are going to hell so [__] fast
i'll tell you what i haven't seen it yet
so maybe we'll do a review did you see
did you
i saw the trailers i
sent haven't seen
clip of somebody saying that cowboy
bebop is like watching um seinfeld in
space i saw that clip that's probably
why i haven't seen it because when they
i saw that clip first i was like did i
just ruin this for myself
because i saw the first like i think a
couple episodes i can't remember i i
didn't like it but i was like this is a
little too accurate so it felt like a
sitcom with no laugh track yeah and you
know what they're trying to do is
because you know in cowboy bebop the
main character he's such a cool sly guy
yeah right so when he says these lines
that are kind of like one-line hitters i
think in anime when you translate it
from english to japanese it sounds fine
yeah but when you try to actualize it in
english yeah it just sounds it's weird
it's like what are you a [__] douche
why are you talking like that yeah it
was just a really really weird iteration
you know yeah but to go back to matrix
like when i went to
when i was going back watching the first
one and then i went back to the second
one back to back because i never really
done that before i was like these
[__] stole this [__]
i'm like you [__] stole this why
is the second one so bad
so so it i think it ties in with the
entire story though i
okay so watching this part four
made me actually appreciate the second
and third one even more really yeah i
started to like it even more just
because i was digging into the lore
like of what it all meant right
so like i think people get confused as
to what the entire matrix truly is about
yeah right
so like to to cap it off basically we
start with this guy thomas anderson and
he has a pretty dull drab life but he's
also a hacker and he finds this
underground group people who tell him
that they can free him from this world
right but they can't tell him from what
it is but he knows that it feels like a
dream and that nothing is real and so
when they free him he's in this [__]
up
real the real world is [__] up it's
actually a thousand years in the future
and the
robots have taken over the earth and
destroyed all of humanity and they're
just
the what's it just single
like survivors out which one was this
reality and which one was not reality
the red or the blue pill
red pill was reality yeah like how it
really is yeah when you take the red
pill it'll
take you out of the matrix and yeah you
can you wake up in these pods where you
are essentially an energy source for the
machine i would have taken the blue pill
immediately yeah
yeah and so that's the idea right um
the uh there's that character cipher
where he betrays them because he thinks
this real world [__] sucks he wants
to go back he's actually the one that
makes sense yeah he makes a lot of sense
yeah right and um
so he he must go back and he wants to
betray them because this world sucks now
when he betrays them they capture
morpheus so they can get the codes
access code to zion this the last
remaining human city
and
there's this dialogue that people miss
from agent smith that i think is so
important where he gives the history of
the matrix
and he explains like this is the sixth
version of the matrix you know
and the machines
the programmers
they specifically said it to be in 1999.
the pinnacle of humanity they say
before the birth of a.i
they call it pinnacle of
the of humanity because it was when
humans thought for themselves before
they let the machines do all the
thinking for them elon musk yeah
so this movie in 1999 was literally
predicting the future
that in he was saying at this point
before the humans let all the the
you know machines do all the thinking
this is when you guys were at your
greatest around this time like yes we
had the internet we had like web 1.0 but
we had technology that worked for us but
we were still like
we like
a humanity
that thought for itself yeah pretty much
and
this space would allow humans to want to
stay here right because they have the
illusion of choice
you know
and so that was really important because
it was saying like showing how
um
when people want machines to do the
thinking for them it was kind of
alluding towards the day and age we live
in now where we are stuck on our phones
we are stuck in social media we want to
plug in like this is being blue pill
pretty much
you know what's even it's interesting
because there's even something creepy as
this like
on instagram there's an ad that keeps on
being sold to me which is
the uh the program that iremen uses
jarvis
really yeah so there's this other uh
company that's called jarvis something
but basically their platform is trying
to sell you on hey have you ever are you
a blog post writer well how did you use
jarvis it'll just write everything for
you what it's an ai program it's an ai
program that'll write your blog post for
you that kind of like inherently takes
over your personality so you do mad libs
and you write in like you fill in the
blanks and it'll just like learn the way
that you write things and it'll kind of
imitate you which is a little creepy
yeah that's crazy it's really [__]
creepy
so
when when we move on then towards where
we are now
with this matrix
um
[Applause]
off the bat it just doesn't look the
same yeah it's shot digitally that's one
and the other one is that they got rid
of all the wusha
they got rid of all the anime frames
they got rid of all the comic book style
of framing they got rid of
um
you're not color grading
so the color grading part was the thing
that
it made it hard for me to move past
just i couldn't move past it right
because
iconically speaking
matrix set a tone
that a lot of other films took from yeah
specifically that type of color it's
what kind of makes the matrix the matrix
yeah and i was like it felt like i was
watching a different film
but then when when since i've been
watching it multiple times yeah because
of how meta this movie gets
actually there's a purpose and reason
for every
that serves a story okay too for why it
is the way it is
so now this new matrix right it's uh
built by the analyst right um
what's his name neil diamond
what's his what's your patrick here or
something you know bill patrick yeah he
so he is the analyst right he's the new
architect he built this new matrix and
he didn't make it drab and green and and
whatever anymore he's he built it to
play off of our emotions so instead of
1999 he chose 2021
when our society is now
purely based of our emotions and our
reactions our anxieties and our fears
and our hopes through social media
and through pop culture through the
stuff we consume so like
so it made it made a lot of sense as to
why the matrix is the way it is now yeah
right but at the same time the way it
looks like that i'm sure it's because
the warner brother heads and they were
parodied in the movie as the video game
marketing team right yeah and they were
straight up just talking about what the
matrix did for culture and why why the
matrix is important
and he was just parroting probably this
meeting he was actually in yeah yeah
like the other meeting with um his boss
too their boss specifically says our
parent company warner brothers is going
to make the matrix for with or without
you and that's a real thing that
happened
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and to the
wachowskis yeah and so like they just
[__] went with it fine if you are
gonna make it anyway then it still has
to have my touch or whatever right
and you can see that the studio had all
these demands
for what they think what makes the
matrix great and what they think the
audience is going to like about it yeah
right and in turn
just so mad at wanna watch husky
she
she mocked it she mocks her own matrix
in the guise of mocking the studio heads
yeah yeah yeah right you think all this
thing that made matrix is so great so
awesome well like in the story the
machines take those stories and they
turn to a video game and they mock your
achievements they mock your dreams yeah
like they mock your home
right and so i started to appreciate it
a little more i still don't like the
delivery you know yeah i still don't
like that when you say it like this like
i i do understand
concept wise is really great
execution to me was so terrible it's bad
it's just like
like i said because i like the matrix so
much and just to kind of wrap back to
you know what we were talking about the
difference between like digital and
practical effects it does make a fat
difference yeah like that frame rate
changing their bullet type oh
oh dude indigestible like
when you go back like i'm not sure if
you guys have watched the first matrix
like it's been a while go watch it again
yeah and you'll see what we're talking
about just like
we could even go back to a film like
alien
right the very first alien if you guys
have no idea if you if you've never if
you're younger and you haven't watched
alien the first one
you are going to see how amazing
practical effects are yeah and how it
holds up that's why terminator 2
holds up really well today too it's just
like simple chrome animations right but
wow [__] wow yeah it's pretty amazing
man like when i look back at it and i
see um like the the very first alien and
i'm like i can't believe somebody built
this
you know all that [__] people have to
put together oh my god but here's the
crazy part
watching matrix 4 made me think man they
got a small budget for this
actually it was the most expensive
matrix movie it cost like 200 million
dollars
yeah which you makes you think where
where did that money go
but i guess they did a lot of practical
car crashes in san francisco there was
like a bunch of complaints apparently
oh for real yeah like they could have
saved that money yeah there was they
the first matrix had the smallest budget
of them all and still a hundred percent
way better
visually and just started 100 200
it's a [__] marvel film dude yeah
exactly and that was the problem with it
was that they were trying to make a
blockbuster movie out of it right the
formula blockbuster movie but the matrix
wasn't a formula blockbuster it's such a
unique [__] film that other
blockbusters took from right so it did
take some story beats it was a little
bit of a reboot but that was part of the
idea of an infinite loop kind of
happening yeah yeah yeah so do you do
you know what the entire matrix trilogy
is like actually actually about you know
where this one comes from no so i mean
you know the story of the one basically
in in the first one well
in the second and third one
um
what they do is turn that idea of the
one on its head
that the one was actually it's not real
the one was just in a
mode of control to control humans to
manipulate humans to think that he's
their savior yeah so
like okay
the whole history of pretty much the
matrix basically is there was a
human machine war right and the machines
won straight up and once they took over
the earth they started turning humans
into
energy sources right
and so the matrix 1.0 the thing that put
them in a dream state so they can draw
power out of them was to make them happy
they made a perfect matrix right yeah
and the thing was though the humans
couldn't accept it because it was too
perfect this isn't real this is not
reality and when they realized that all
these humans started waking up and they
said entire crops died and they lost a
lot of energy and power so they had to
reset it and this time because they're
binary machines they made a nightmare
matrix
right that's where the merivinjian and
those two pale ass freaks yeah yeah they
come from right though they're ghosts
werewolves vampires right so they made
this nightmare matrix to
um
to bring fear and all these brain
patterns come out of their heads to draw
power
but at the same time the humans didn't
accept that they wanted out yeah
obviously right [__] fickle ass
people so by the third matrix the
architect right uh in the the machines
they
created a program called the oracle
yeah right and her program was to
understand humans right and to calculate
so far ahead
and of what's going to happen by the
algorithms that they're feeding the
humans right and that algorithm is
choice
they they said if you give them choice
or at least the illusion of choice then
they'll stay they'll stay in the matrix
right and it worked except
the
sum of every decision made by everybody
in the matrix subconsciously or
unconsciously turned into this
code called the anomaly
right
and that code anomaly would destroy the
matrix in turn destroying everybody
that's plugged in yeah killing the
entire crops again so what the architect
and oracle do
is they take that code and implement and
put it in a human
into neo
right so in the first movie so what they
also do right this is all this is all
expository you know when neo goes and
meet the oracle and then they just talk
and talk and talk on the bench and then
there's a big burly brawl right and then
he goes to the architect and they just
talk and talk an expert this is
basically what they're talking about
so
yeah so the whole idea was then that the
architect in oracle
created a story
right of the one right so that the
humans would believe that he is their
savior
right and so the machines built a city
called zion right and all that one
percent of people who want to get free
and get out they get led into zion right
that's actually zion's trash can you
know your recycle bin yeah yeah yeah
that's actually recycle bin all those
faulty power sources that keep getting
out
they want to lead them there not only
that they want this anomaly that they
control right they can only control that
code if it's in a human because you can
manipulate a human yeah and to do that
the oracle gave this program this of
love for humanity right so he would be
the one the savior the superhero the
type right
so that in nebulae he would lead these
people who want free from the matrix
these buggy faulty energy sources
in the trash can
so that they'll destroy zion and kill
all those people
so this was actually part of their
system being free and and the one and
all these people is almost
planned is part of the control that they
have
right and so
what that
one or the anomaly guy
he his end would be to go back to the
source that big baby face um robot thing
yeah you know um and restart the matrix
basically reboot and save all those
people plugged in
you know and then they just start over
in a loop
and so that has happened six times
already so by the time matrix part one
happens that's the sixth time that loop
has happened but in matrix we loaded
matrix part two
it's revealed that the oracle we learned
is a computer program
inevitably turning
to us learning that neo is also a
computer program yeah
you know and he
this version of neo though the oracle
right
she was tired of having to exterminate
all these humans you know by the
hundreds of thousands if not millions
every cycle is just murdering destroying
them right and so she had a bigger plan
of brokering peace between the humans
and the machines finally because they've
just been at war for thousands of years
yeah
and her plan was now to inflate a
different code of love into neo
which is a love for trinity
and trinity also has another code
implanted into her that's why in the
first matrix when she kisses him he
comes back to life it's because she
accesses that an anomaly code in him
right
and then he goes into
agent smith destroys him right
but what happened in that point though
like agent smith is supposed to go to
the source to be recycled destroyed or
whatever right but because the anomaly
code was copied onto him aka the one
code that's why mr uh agent smith came
back and he's crazy powerful yeah but he
also has this compulsion to copy and
copy and copy
his virus
became a virus yeah right
and that
the code that was given into neo to love
trinity now
was made to prevent him from having
trinity to die
rather than preventing humanity to die
yeah right so by the time he goes to see
the architect he's there's two doors
right go through this door go to the
source and we're gonna reset the matrix
we're gonna save everybody in those pods
and
you know zion's gonna be destroyed or
go back and try to save this girl you're
not gonna save her she's gonna die and
we're gonna kill everybody anyways
that's essentially what the architect is
saying
right and what's he choose he chooses
this time right because all the other
iterations before him went to the source
but the oracle planned this part for him
to choose to go to the other door and
save trinity yeah instead of going this
going to the source and restarting it
leading into the events of matrix
revolutions which shows that the oracle
had planned
this virus of the agent to take over the
matrix
to became to become a bartering deal
between neo and the machines to broker
peace finally this was all in the
oracle's plans it was all planned out
yeah that's crazy yeah and so
that way that uh
neo goes and tries to fight him and
without
actually defeating him when he gets
copied into him
the source finally gets access to agent
smith and destroys his code
yeah yeah yeah yeah and
they neo even though he gives his life
that piece is brokered
the machines
finally
stop destroying zion yeah right and
that's where matrix four picks up when
they go see naobi
you know she's like 90 something years
old and she says what happened after
like the oracle dream happened that's
why you like i had a problem after
seeing these cute [__] robots yeah
cause you know in the first three
matrices the robots were the [__]
like gross enemy they were just these
octopus [__] murderous things yeah
and now you got like these cute robots
jumping around and then i thought about
it like oh like
the oracle wanted this
she wanted to see a future where the
machines and humans work together to
build a better life on earth and it was
happening it was starting there and in
my mind would think like yeah if i was a
crazy looking machine and i wanted to
help the humans i think i would change
up my whole look to be more acceptable
yeah you know to be more trustworthy not
this crazy you know tentacle monster
it's like one of those like audrey's
that try to be super cool with the young
kids
hey man what's up
[Laughter]
so so i just gave the whole lore
basically yeah that's what i mean i
appreciate that they stuck to the lore
and they started explaining like
you know if you understood what was
going on till then
to what's happening now
is that the analyst now has taken over
they've purged the architect in the
oracle yeah right but the oracle's dream
has lived out now for the last 60 years
i guess
the humans and robots are starting to
work together and
what had happened after mexico's
revolutions was
part of the peace deal was whoever wants
to be free from the matrix will be set
free and so millions were set free and
they built this city of io
yes new city and in turn with that
happening the machines lost all these
this power
and that caught it caused a civil war so
a new power has risen up
you know to control this new matrix
that's why even though this one flopped
it actually did really bad apparently i
do want to see it continue to see where
it's going to go see where it's going to
go because if you if you appreciate the
lore of the matrix and where it's going
then i want to know what happens i mean
the lore from the way you explain it
like
it kind of pieced together a lot of
things for me like it makes sense
but i just hated the delivery so yeah
like why
like the way you explain it sounds
pretty amazing but then when you watch
this it's like
yeah what the [__] is this yeah you have
to sit through like this is one of the
first movies where i couldn't wait until
the exposition happened and wanted to
skip the action yeah something about the
action was so
cookie cutter or drab or like it could
have been on a tv show yeah that's what
it felt like to me that fight in that
warehouse was so convoluted was so which
it did that stupid american style of
fast cuts
shaky cam [__] and i was like dude
like
i was like am i watching a cw show
you know
the [__] was pissing me off that's i
started looking at this like it looks
like it's the same dp across all the
other warner brothers movies up there
all their other blockbusters yeah it's
got the same color tone too like and
like i said that was the analyst saying
i made this matrix to be more colorful
yeah he said that too yeah you know
and at the end was pretty important too
how
just like i was saying like cypher you
know he was saying these people here
they want to stay here they want you
know certainty they want all these
things like they're not going to want to
leave this matrix which makes sense
considering we're all stuck to our
phones true yeah because if i had that
option i'd be like i'm staying
i would too yeah i'm like i'm good yeah
if there was a way like if that future
was like
humans are are like [__] batteries
and there's no worth living
without a sun yeah just give me a
digital sun then yeah i'm okay because
pump vitamin three yeah vitamin d
through my neck
it's interesting though like what with
the concept of matrix 2 just the idea of
you know
kind of like what happiness and reality
is right yes
that's the part that always like with
the majors kind of [__] me up a little
bit because
if reality is simply
is what we create in our head what's
real what's fake yeah you know like
who's to say that them living in that
matrix isn't real but you you walk
around and you see a lot of people who
do live in their own reality they live
in their own little story where they're
the hero of the world right yeah you
mean a lot of people like that
you know and and
the matrix really did
put that on your head that's the point
that the
the machines take advantage of is that
humans have this tendency to do that so
this matrix the new matrix is to yeah
give them that that's what there's all
these bots to allow them to live out
these weird little dreams yeah yeah
like that whole overarching theme is
always like control
and choice yeah
but the biggest struggle you see with
neo in the the original trilogy was
between him and oracle because he is a
program but he
he rebels against that consistently yeah
through the films about
still wanting to make his own choices
yet at the end he still fulfilled
oracle's prophecies yeah right even
though he was trying to make his own
choice it's interesting too where how
i think like the way it's described now
is like what's really in your control
you don't know what the [__] is in your
control yeah it's it kind of goes with
this idea of just like the article is
supposed to be like this omnipotent
being you know like it's
oracle's god yes
you know like you think that the reason
like the reason why you took this step
forward is because you made the choice
to your brain activated this thought
that said hey i'm going to move these
muscles to move forward the oracle's
saying this was already planned out yeah
and that was actually played out like
people think it's kind of awkward but
then that scene when he sees her after
he runs into
serif the
asian dude with the on white wearing the
sunglasses so he's supposed to be a
login screen right he's a security block
yeah yeah yeah right so he um so when
neil gets past that
he um talks to her and she goes sit down
and goes i'll stand
and then he sits down he goes i felt
like sitting and she does that of course
you did yeah but it's just the fact that
he's trying to get out of her control
yeah but he just can't like he is a
program i think people miss that part
yeah they still see the humanity in neo
um because he is a human but then there
is that anomaly code in him which causes
like you know when at the end of
reloaded he [__] hits those tentacle
sentinels
you know and i was so confused about it
what the [__] how do you do that yeah
and until i learned about the code when
he did that he actually touched the
source too
so
like that's part of the entire lord that
see that's the thing that you explained
that to me like i didn't get that in the
film yeah i'm like how do you duke in
these fools yeah so the anomaly code is
i guess a very powerful code but like um
the other part about this new matrix is
that trinity has the power of the ones
right which is kind of confusing but
remember neo saved her life when she was
falling off that building and then he
started her heart again when he touched
he went inside her pretty much that was
when he also imparted the code got
copied into her
just like it went copied into smith yeah
yeah so that's why that bond that they
have
creates so much energy as the analyst
was saying but if they put them together
quote-unquote bad things happen
so he kept them at a distance pretty
much and what he was doing was torturing
them
right
yeah he tortures them to get this brain
activity to be so close yet so far
to generate all this power yeah for the
matrix yeah which i appreciated better
because the other matrix it was just
like weird batteries and it's just that
apparently the original idea was that we
were actually computer processors for
the machines our brains our
organic brains but the studio back then
apparently was like i don't think the
audience will understand it because we
didn't really know what computers were
yeah back then people still don't
understand that yeah would have made no
damn difference but i like how they
still made it energy but then that our
brain activity generates energy for the
machine i wonder if they were like if
they look back and they go this is way
too complicated for people yeah and then
they saw interstellar and they're like
they're like wait a second yeah we could
have done that yes okay yeah any one of
that [__] film just like what
the [__] just happened
it's a whole like it's all about
dimensions and layers on layers on
layers but um another thing i wanted to
bring up was um
the bachowski's since the first matrixes
have
transitioned
that's right they're the sisters now
yeah they weren't the only ones though
there's the wachowskis and also the um
i don't know
there's somebody else too i'm sorry this
is another director uh brother that also
became women or they are women then they
trans i don't know um
i don't know i'm sorry i'm not trying to
be disrespectful i just i don't know
what the terminology is but because they
they know they're
women women yeah so that part like a lot
of people had suspected that the matrix
was an allegory to transitioning to
transgenderism
and the what which housekeys actually
came out a couple years ago and
confirmed it that they did make it as an
allegory for transitioning
right about becoming free and coming
into the real world
right so remember but then the real
world sucks exactly that was the idea is
that when they transition genders that
it's going to suck for them
but they'll be free they will be who
they really are but the real world also
sucks
yeah yeah yeah that was the idea so
there was that character switch she was
like the androgynous females with the
white hair no not like this yeah
so
in the matrix she's like this this uh
like
uh
androgynous uh female
but when she wakes up in the real world
they were supposed to cast a man it was
supposed to be a dude but when he goes
in the matrix he's a female yeah so the
idea was like she was represent like
transgender
character that when she grew up in the
matrix she was assigned a female
but in her head she always knew that she
was mad so when she gets free from the
matrix she wakes up and her real body is
a male and the studio made them cut that
that would have been so important today
right yeah that would have that would
have been like yo this is ahead of its
time yeah yeah so but that the
overarching story though is you know
does kind of tell the story of the
people transitioning of people really
trying to figure out who they really are
in this world and the choices that they
make
yeah yeah how interesting
damn that's actually [__] deep as
[__] yeah dude like the matrix goes d
yeah and that's why i [__] love it
it's just
like at the same time it was executed
very well it's a film it's just okay
this fourth one
okay they
they dive into it they get into it there
is the lord there i just didn't
appreciate the execution i didn't like
neil patrick harris's character
i mean i understood the the the
purpose that he had but then i i i guess
it's just trying to say that all these
programs do have different personalities
because the architect was this super
calculating father figure and architect
i mean the oracle was this loving mother
figure right yes with the mother and
father the matrix and this analyst is
just this [__] douchebag who took it
over yeah you know and i i just was just
kind of hard when it leaves idea that
there he's a he's a program i feel like
for me
i almost wish i didn't watch matrix one
i should have just watched
two and three before i watched four
because i watched one and i went
straight to four and then it was just
there's a whole
yeah i was like what what like i said
like what in the [__] wbcw [__] is
this dude
[Laughter]
this is coming on after smackdown
look at this [__] one hour [__]
youtube sketch dude that i'm watching
right now that's why it's so hard to
believe wow 200 million dollars yeah i
got to see because it definitely wasn't
because i know when it comes to films a
lot of the the budget has to go into
marketing it wasn't in this film
so where the [__] did that money go
i don't know man like there was enough
hype for it that
you just kind of wonder like
it was like either because like the
wachowskis
didn't want to do it but
um apparently for lana wachowski
both of them their parents died yeah and
then also one of their close friends
also died and that made one of the
sisters drop out and that actually
motivated the other sister to continue
yeah so
it made me think maybe the other sister
was the one with the eye for the anime
and action yeah maybe maybe that's what
happened like they needed both of them
but like
that's why i'm assuming maybe lana isn't
the action director that the other uh i
forgot what the other sister's name was
i've got uh moses posted this thing um
we have a buddy named moses moses posted
this thing where uh on his instagram a
while back but it was in stories where
it was it was a compilation of all these
films that were frame by frame animes
right
and it was like i like all these films i
didn't know i'm like the [__] oh yeah
that the matrix like
copied that composition yeah yeah yeah
yeah that that last scene of um
ghost in the shell when they're finding
that it's the hallways fight it's a
lobby scene in the matrix right
it's just so beautiful and there are
parts where they try to copy it but like
i honestly think this look bullet time
what it is today you could do so much
for some reason i just felt like this
version of it was so whack yeah it was
either the frame rates of him being so
choppy and the open shutters
or it was just the goofiness behind it
as well yeah yeah it was a bit goofy
right this film like tone was just all
over the place the new morpheus 2 was a
epic goofy i call him [__] dork dude
[__] dork dude i just
it's all that [__] man i was like what
the [__] is this dweeb i was like so
annoyed
so yeah it's like he's he's the program
that neil wrote within the matrix yeah
so in the matrix neil made a video game
so the program and he made it open
source so that somebody out there
could reach him
right i guess it was a subconscious
thing
and the actual crew of real people
went into the matrix then hacked into
his video game and that's why they were
seeing it in first person
so that first
scene opening scene is they're actually
inside a video game which was kind of
fun
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah but that's the
idea of it being meta quote okay you
watched it so many times dude
i would have never picked up anything
because i was stuck in quarantine i wish
i could have saw spider-man four more
times but i was stuck with the matrix so
i watched it over and over again one
thing i really appreciated about
spider-man was just um
it was the cg effects like all the cg
[__] looks so good right you know right
and
just to wrap it back to shanghai
i'm like why couldn't they do the same
for that [__] movie man well well
here's what i also thought about it
considering uh matrix though was when
they cut out all those great [__]
action scenes like the fight scenes that
were on the previous ones i was like why
did they take that out and in my head it
made me think that maybe the studio
thought like kung fu was was not cool
anymore
right so they didn't go back to get um
yeah yeah yeah yeah like legendary
like fight choreographer and wire work
choreographer and they cut all that
stuff out right he was the one that they
gave him his own film with uh
with uh what's his face with uh neo
what's his name keanu reeves keanu
reeves tai chi master is it
if you guys are watching this on video i
wish you could see my face
this is literally one of the worst films
i've ever seen in my life like i was so
disappointed and pissed how they did him
like that
there was this
it's literally one of the funniest films
i've ever seen
this is that that last fight scene where
he just jumps into the river like the
hudson river and just swims
i didn't see it now so
i forgot what the whole concept was but
keanu reeves just consistently kept
saying at the end you owe me a life you
know because keanu reeves can't not
sound like keanu reeves
you know and he's a and keanu reeves is
the antagonist he's a villain
and he's like he he just repeatedly says
he's lying you owe me a life he aimed me
alive and i'm like what the [__] is
going on here but essentially
um keanu reeves he escapes this last
fight scene that he has right and
they're on this like platform and stage
where everybody's fighting each other
and how he evades and escapes like the
police and everybody he just jumps into
the like the hudson river or some [__]
and he just swims across it so it's a
tai chi matches scent in new york or
something like that i don't know where
the [__] it is it's like in the states
or some [__] but he i mean i haven't
seen the movie in a long time but just
that one scene he just jumps into the
water and then he just swims away to
freedom i'm like so he just swam like 30
miles his credits roll
i think he got caught later on i was
like
what in the [__] is going on
i think that's the the problem with this
new matrix though is that i like i said
i felt like the studio thought that like
kung fu wasn't cool anymore actually
kung fu films but then chongqi came out
now this is what i'm saying
i wish there was shangchi level of fight
fighting choreography in this matrix oh
that would have been great i think it
would have filled in a lot of gaps
it would have gave me something to bite
on yeah for sure at the same time though
the fight scenes
in this matrix didn't mean anything yeah
like when neo faces agent smith it
[__] meant something oh my god he
says he's starting to believe right when
he starts to believe that he's the one
he starts beating the [__] out of agent
smith
right like and like
each fights even the the conversation
with the architect that's a [__]
fight scene right it's just a fight
scene with dialogue yeah yeah yeah right
and the way he won that fight was by
making his own choice not by the choices
he was given
by the architect because they're in
control of him and by him beating the
architect is him making his own choice
and going towards the other door right
this new matrix they fought just to
fight yeah just say hey remember i still
know
that's what i was like what is this
pointless fighting going on like so the
mayor of indian shows back up right
he
was having a rant in the middle of this
big fight going on right
and i felt like that was probably the
director saying like what he's saying is
way more important than this fighting
yeah right which kind of pissed me off
like because what he's saying is
important because he's complaining about
this new matrix the smartphones the
texting the social media the video games
and all that and he says we used to have
style we used to have class we used to
have conversations now look at this [__]
this facebook zuckerberg [__] yeah
yeah yeah and that's why he's so angry
because he was he lost that all in this
new version the matrix with everything
we have now people like him are
like worthless in this matrix yeah yeah
yeah yeah and that was way more
important than
the fight that was happening in the
background like i don't know what the
[__] whoever this new version of agent
smith came for no reason to
say something and then they start
fighting and
what and then he walks away
like and then he goes sees trinity
and then more exposition from the
analyst explaining
where he is yeah it's just the whole
film too like and the reason why i don't
have much to say about it i didn't like
it like
like
you know
you know to wrap it back to shanghai
it's like the reason why i had more to
say about chang cheese because there was
things i liked about it and there was
things i disliked about it yeah you know
so there was just more things to talk
about right and it was something that i
was really really invested in yeah with
matrix it was just
i don't know like for me too it's
i'm glad that you explained the lord now
it starts to like piece up and make a
little sense so now i probably if i
watch it again it'll probably feel a lot
better yeah but because it was so just
chopped up and stupid yeah i just got
really upset watching it i was just just
irritated the whole time they they keep
bringing up the theme of choice as well
right and that was important to the
maravingian
right because like i said he's part of
that second nightmare matrix
and um he brought up the whole idea that
choice is an illusion because he knows
he was in the matrix before the one
before he was replaced by the oracle
yeah right that's why he hates the
oracle so much and he wants the eyes of
the oracle
um and he shows
by example that he says that choice is
an illusion in this matrix and let me
show you and what he does is he feeds
this girl some orgasm cake
right and i think the allegory there
being that being controlled by these
programs and machines is akin to like
sexual assault like it's it's a
violation yeah and that's why your
freedom and your choice is so important
and then like
where is any of that allegory going on
here it's just like
it was just so basic yeah everything was
so basic and then you know if you put it
like that too all the stuff they were
setting up in the second and third one
there was just a lot of stuff that was
missed too then you know for me it just
i just
i don't know man yeah
like i said because of how much i loved
the first one and once again i made the
mistake of watching the first one yeah
and before i watched that [__] because
it just all pieced so well together like
i it's very
i think when we talk about cult classics
too we're talking about films that
really just kind of changed the
landscape of film in general yeah like
even even like this film right think
about the movie 300 right right 300
changed the landscape of [__] action
films dude speed ramps would never be
the same since 300
yeah after 300 every [__] action
scene had speed ramps yeah and
superheroes couldn't look like nicolas
cage anymore yeah you had to be jacked
you had to be on a program
dude gerard butler dude
so [__] buff very odd that he had a
thick scottish accent yeah
man nice uh greek warrior there
[Laughter]
hi lottie
what the [__] is that
this is scotland
but
yo apparently he they told them all
right you have to be jacked we need you
to live this much you got to look like
this you can come train with us and blah
blah and he's like
i'll see you in in like in 90 days and
then apparently he came back and he was
just
they had the 300 workout the gerard
butler 300 workout and then i remember
jones yeah my buddy uh in college he
tried doing it and he threw up in the
gym
because it was that [__] hard yeah
but they also forgot that this
[__] was on the sauce yeah he
was he was cycled dude all these people
have you seen this that channel more
plays more dates
so more play sport dates is a guy that
he's a self-proclaimed like i wouldn't
say steroid expert but the guy cycles
himself and he's a very very intelligent
guy okay um he has a background like in
chemistry and biology and all other
stuff
so his thing is it's just literally
uncut him talking for like an hour about
what the steroid cycle that somebody
might have been taking so what am i
looking at just by looking at them and
seeing like certain things because
he's he has a background i've seen
channels like that like natty or
something else i forget so like now
you're not or whatever but yeah moore
plays more dates is he is really good at
breaking everything down right so one of
the person people that he broke down was
uh camille
um yeah the
the eternal's got eternal guy right
stand up comic really funny dude and
he's just like like i mean
you didn't really need to see the video
just to know this was on steroids yeah
you know but he breaks that like for
example like he he'll do um an idea of
what type of steroids they were taking
and what the cycle was on like for
example thor yeah right like how he just
blew the [__] up yeah you know and he
was like okay this is probably what he
was taking at what time and and what it
does exactly so it's kind of fascinating
and i think a lot of people don't know
even though you guys keep hearing it is
that there's a lot of people that are on
steroids a lot i mean like i can't
believe people just look at the rock
like wow well like you know i
it's so weird to see like clearly the
symptoms of steroid abuse like having an
interview with the president of the
united states of america like this guy
is on
a narcotic i think
clearly like look at the size of his
head now yeah people don't ever question
it it's like dude of course he's on
roids yeah but and you know and
there was a guy so years ago there was a
dude uh he probably doesn't remember
this now but he is super jacked i think
he's from the uk and he lives in l.a i
think he's like a millionaire
millionaire now because he made so much
money yeah but it was a guy named simeon
panda simeon panda dude is like a
specimen the guy is
jacked beyond belief like when you look
at him he looks like a [__] superhero
right he's got that major v going bro
dude he's like he looks insane so years
ago when instagram just started and this
is when memes just came out
and
so i can't remember what the exact
picture what what the exact uh meme was
or what the joke was about it but it was
a picture of simeon panda flexing and
he's jacked the [__] i just i used to
just repost some memes every now and
then but he uh i guess he didn't flex
one of his pecs and so one of his tits
were hella tiny and the other one was
huge
and so i think it was something mimi
that said natty or not and the bottom
said more like titty or not you know and
i just posted because i thought it was a
funny meme yeah and then this fool wrote
on the comments and he just he was like
well guess what you're not even [__]
funny and i'm like who is this
i don't know who the [__] the guy was
so this guy simeon panda was mad at me
some fat [__] asian kid and i wasn't
even making i just reposted i didn't
make the [__] meme you know right did
you like threaten you like kick your ass
yeah he was like writing all this [__]
and i just wrote i was like who are you
question mark he goes i'm the guy in the
photo
and i'm like cool i was like did i hurt
your feelings question mark yeah dude
that's i think when you're bringing that
up i i do remember like reading those he
was so insecure he was so insecure major
insecure about his pecs it's like but
your pecs are big yeah you know
look at i'm not making fun of you i just
reposted to me yeah he's like look at
the photos zero body fat like we know
it's like
ak guy yeah so i think the part that
really pissed him off i was like this is
what i wrote and this is kind of an
[__] thing for me to do i was like i
was like i was like i'm sorry so if you
just write that i hurt your feelings
i'll take the photo down did i hurt your
feelings question mark and i put a heart
at the end of it
right and he just started going off at
that point he goes like oh he was like
you [__] people out here but just
kind of like you know making fun of me
or whatever but all my subscribers like
bro it's a meme he didn't make the
[__] meme i don't understand if you
have a body of a god yet have no
confidence in yourself i can't
understand that like look at you but you
know i was asking a bunch of bodybuilder
people too because you know like you
know at barbell there's a lot of buff
people he goes dude the strongest
buffest people are the most insecure
human beings it's their their lifting is
their overcompensation yeah and you know
to me as somebody who's like a flabby
guy i can't really understand that yeah
so when i look at him i'm like why are
you so caught up on this [__] it's like
i'm not making fun of you i just posted
this funny [__] meme i didn't make it
and i wrote just like i didn't make this
bro
i didn't create i don't even know that's
why when he wrote to me i was like who
are you
i was like i don't even know who you are
i was like just say that i hurt your
feelings don't take the photo down he
goes no you're just not funny i was like
did i hurt your feelings question mark
you're just not funny and i'm like bro
you are so [__] sensitive man like
relax dude i've literally been memed all
over the internet you'll see me [__]
pulling a fit i don't know why people
can't
understand
being laughed at or laughing with they
can't understand that difference yeah be
like to to see a joke for what it is
yeah it's like obviously dude you're i
mean also too guy like
you're
dope
you're so buff dude
not only that's a [__] good looking
dude too and he's also a
multi-millionaire i'm like it's like why
are you coming at me yeah it's like you
know like i'm an ant in your universe
and in fact if we met in person you
could crush me
like even if he doesn't fight at all you
could kill me if you if you grab me i'm
done yeah you know what i mean so it's
like for him like i just i mean
obviously he just has to probably do
with a lot of personal issues maybe it's
one of those early days of the internet
yeah it was pretty early instagram it
was like eight nine years ago yeah
people had a really tough time with bad
comments back then yeah and i know i did
i think we all did yeah i think it was
just a little weird that i explained it
was a little too personal it was so
personal as if i knew him that's why i
was confused it's like did we meet
before yeah and i didn't understand what
was going on and i'm like wait you're a
famous bodybuilder like you know like
like i said i didn't make the joke
somebody else did this this is a repost
but yeah this is a repo i reposted
somebody else's [__] what are you
it was already well known like people
already saw this photo i didn't create
it i mean the thing is going back to it
though man the steroids make our
superheroes look dope oh for sure i kind
of wish keanu went on a cycle
i wish you were doing some kung fu again
man i mean like it didn't look that
great like
i mean the way he trained for matrix one
i heard it was very extensive brutal
apparently he had broken his neck in
some
like stunt practice
and he still showed up with a neck brace
like doing learning all the choreography
that's [__] crazy i remember seeing
like behind the scenes videos where he's
like
oh
[__] like yeah he was in pain and that's
why
i think you can see by this second and
third movie when he's throwing his kicks
he's super like leaning backwards yeah
his neck yeah his neck wasn't great his
kicks were amazing in the first one i
mean that the whole fight choreography
like
before matrix one right we had our
our hong kong flicks action flicks like
you would you couldn't necessarily find
them in even like blockbusters you had
to find some mommy pot
specialty specialty shops with like
these niche like movies right so back
then like for me my favorite movies were
actually a lot of jet li movies so like
black mask
and uh legend the fist of legend and a
bunch of these other films then i
learned like oh wait these were all
no no no
what a waste of [__] jet leading
no but
going back you you see that um those are
all yuen won films yeah that he
choreographed and that's why like matrix
has that look of what it is each fight
scene was just so important and it was
all telling a story about neo's progress
and this one was fight to remember who
you are yeah
[Laughter]
it's like dude haven't i done enough
yeah like god damn it it was still
interesting like in in the sense like i
said the anomaly code being copied into
trinity and her she originally gave that
kiss to neo
but apparently this time around it was
when they kissed on the rooftop
that code was awakened in trinity that's
how she learned to fly before it was
awakened in neo as well
so
and all in all it made sense as far as
story and more goes
but yeah putting it all together was
just a jumbled mess dude i would i would
love to fly man somebody gave me that
code it's just you just gotta believe
that apparently if you believe this is a
simulation yeah
you could fly
after this podcast is over i'ma tell
[__] head to shoot a bullet
just wake me up
just watch bro well guys that wraps up
this episode of the genius brain podcast
i hope you enjoyed that i hope you
learned a lot about the matrix i hope
you uh i wonder what you guys thought
about spider-man i thought it was pretty
[__] amazing man and um
made up for a lot of shitty spider-man
films for me yeah what did you think
about the matrix directions
well you guys can catch ed at ed park v
p and you can see genius pranks every
sundays at 12 p.m uh make sure that you
guys check us out uh listen to us on
itunes spotify and if you're watching us
on youtube we will see you all next time
peace